Welcome back.
I got too excited, and I went 20
seconds over time-- I hope
YouTube still lets me publish
this video, so I'll try my
best.
What I was saying is how related
these two formulas
are, and that makes sense
because at this point the ball
is stationary-- it's completely
the same as a ball
just being dropped, a stationary
ball being dropped
from height h.
We can use this formula to do
the same thing that we did
intuitively in the last video.
If we're just dropping a ball,
the initial velocity is zero,
so this term goes to zero,
and this term is the
only one that matters.
Once again, if we're dropping
it, we started at height h and
we go to zero, so the change
in distance is now minus h.
We have at squared over 2, and
that equals gravity times--
what's the time?
The time is not this full t0,
it's t0 over 2, so g t0 over 2
squared over 2.
You multiply both sides times
negative 1, and you get this
exact same thing.
That's pretty cool.
What I love about physics it
that there's so many ways to
approach the problems. You can
actually start off with any
one of the formulas that we've
been looking at, and as long
as you kind of keep playing
with it and keep thinking
about it, you might not find
the fastest route to the
solution, but as long as you
don't do anything incorrect,
you will get the solution.
Hopefully, this gives you a
little bit of an intuition of
projectile motion.
In the next set of videos,
we're going to make it
slightly more complicated, but
also slightly more realistic.
I'm going to introduce you
to what happens in
two-dimensional motion-- it's
when you're not throwing
something straight up, but you
actually throw something at an
angle like you normally do.
I'll see you in the
next video.